you talk about everyone always talks
about failing and you talk about you
know being scared of failing - and I
love that I think I think cuz that
really gets the essence of it yeah that
that's what hairdressers have a lot of
here that that's good it's got it all
that was a big one
I'm in a funny place where I'm just not
scared I'm just not worried about you
know it's like this weird I could care
less what anybody thinks and I genuinely
care what everybody thinks you know it's
the kind of this really yin and yang and
so I just realized that so many of you
are scared to fail because your dad's
gonna make you feel bad about it and I'm
I've empathy for that that sucks like or
or your or your husband is gonna say I
told you so
I'm very fascinated by negative energy
within our ecosystem that is not cut out
a bull you can get rid of your
acquaintance that's a [ __ ] right but
when your mom's the dick face you're in
trouble yeah and and so I've been trying
to have this conversation of who are you
scared to fail in front of and I gotta
tell you in one on one's or meetups
where the content has come from people
people are scared like you know you look
up to your older sister who's straight
line and got that like and her opinion
matters to you but you're an artist and
you want to do this and if you fail you
don't want to fail in front of her
that's tough that's stopping a lot of us
I don't have the answer to what you have
to do about it other than I do believe
that communication solves all things but
great how do I push you to have that
real talk with your mom hard so yeah man
it's it's a real one but it's not so
easy to unwind
you